哈囉我是夏森林
咱們油豆機真的是太容易被防晒温鬥了
你們看我這個大包
就是是防晒釋出來的
看在我這麼努力的份上可以給我一個小心心嗎
這次給大家分享一下
我目前正在用的一些比較喜歡的部門鬥的防晒
我為了這一期防晒的是屏幕買了一堆的防晒回來時
我是那種特別的温鬥温避口的膚質
這一些防晒都是我用了很久確定不會温鬥的
但想給你們先說這個
這是一個粉絲寶貓給我推薦的
我很感謝他
他很好用是一種主意的致敵
我開之後很乾爽
一點都不油膩
沒有負擔感
也不假白
在我臉上大概是有0.5度的體量效果
它是一隻蠢物裡膀塞但是它的膚感還做得這麼好
我很喜歡它
沒有相驚也沒有色素
我覺得它很適合日常通起來使用
適合油豆機和油米機的寶貓
然後就是黑膠袋防晒
在我第一期的防晒和自己連它就出現
它也是這種乳炎
壯油一點凝露的致敵
一抹開就會變得神水的
幾秒鐘之後臉就會變得很乾爽
不凡白上臉沒有顏色
也是不寒酒精香精框油的
我也很喜歡它推薦給油豆機的寶貓
第三款是它
我之前在購物分享的連收過
它是一隻物化結合的防晒
它是可以防水的
我喜歡在有護牙暈用的時候用它
它是這種塘桿葉的致敵
用前是需要搖一搖的
抹開之後性素沉抹會變成一種思榮感
像一顆水泥桃一樣
也是很清爽不年齡的
少也沒有顏色
但是在室內開的空調
沒有開窗的情況下
我感覺它有一點點的把乾
但是它在室外就完全OK
很適合我們游體
第四款是它
這個是我的第二支
它是膚色的
我很喜歡它
之前我有單獨的為它出過一期視頻
因為它的裝感好
對於毛孔的修飾度
比一些大牌的粉底液還要好
而且它好無粉感
可以很自然的修飾膚色
顯得皮膚很好
會有很自然的體量效果
它是這種比較潤的致敬
用手隨便陰我就能抹暈
就算我一用它
用兩三碗也好
壓力一點都不厚重
但它有一個問題
它裡面有一個真日比較大的防晒器
就是它裡面有二本桶
如果很在意的寶寶就不用考慮它了
它不便宜
但是我會一直回落它
它是和乾脆
或油皮用它要配合散粉
不然會感覺出油有點梦
最後一款就是這個潤色隔離
它好難買
我等了它好久
別人說它是CPB隔離的平替
我用起來我覺得它只是和油性幾乎
乾脆用的話
可能會覺得太乾了
是這種粉膚色的
抹開之後也是非常單爽的
但它上臉臉會變得很白
油點粉100的感覺
這個我覺得
更適合皮膚很白很白的油皮
擦擦之後把薄子壓稍微的故意下
不然會有點色差
我一般用它也是直接把它當粉底
用我今天臉上就是用的它
如果我不定裝的話
它其實上完之後是有一種潤白感的
但是臉上又不會感覺黏膩
所以它還是挺妙的
我覺得適合去超適啊
或者是出去六彎
想要自己起座看起來好一點
然後又不想化妝
用完擦妨曬就用這個就很合適
還是要去一些高海把地區那邊
走來現比較強
我們在臉上擦了妨曬之後
再把這支SPS50加的隔離當粉底來用
那臉上的這個妨曬力會更好
那這些就是我目前正在用的
五支妨曬
其實我還有一些妨曬完沒有開始試
我實在是拍長動
之後用了再給你們分享吧
拜拜